[Music]
hey guys and welcome to a super cult
production of congratulations
[Music]
so it's back we're back
congratulations we are back a week later
and it's always a week later when we do
the thing
it's back when we do the week later it's
back when we do a week later is when we
you know what i'm saying dude i don't
want to i want to get to the point in my
life where i'm just saying all the words
in the sentence and then you make the
sentence for me i think that would be
amazing dude
like come on elon musk what are you
doing get it so we can have things in
our head where you just throw you know
how we [ __ ] sentences up all the time
left and right
we'll be like it's it's it's it
you know we'll just do what i just said
right
like sometimes you say
yesterday instead of tomorrow i need to
autocorrect for that come on elon musk
let's get it going dude
um
you know but i don't know maybe i i
don't take gabapentin anymore so it's
like it's not that but sometimes i need
word i think it [ __ ] i need my word
recall is getting worse yes dude my word
recall's getting worse i'm getting older
and i'm 42 right now
and uh you know every time i say my age
i've been i think about i used to be in
this art class i've never said this
before on my podcast but i think about
this kid in this art class
i was like 10 in it
and then every time they asked somebody
how old he was he said nine going on ten
and i always think about it because
obviously ten comes after nine and we
all know it do it people say nine going
on ten and then we have to write in all
of our information on a thing that we
passed around and his and mine came to
me it went to him first and mine came to
me
it went to his first see this would be
one of those times where you could just
understand what i'm saying
uh it went to him first and then i saw
what he put in under age and he wrote it
in the little box nine going on ten and
that's absolutely ridiculous to write it
we know what comes next but he was
insecure about it and we're all insecure
about
we're insecure about you know whatever
we're insecure about there's nothing you
can do about it i mean you can't go to
therapy and [ __ ] and i'm insecure about
being alone and i'm insecure about who i
am as a person but it's all good dude
right we're all insecure about different
things some people are insecure he's
insecure about how he wants to be
perceived as more of a man because he
was also a little bit of a shrimp boat
for nine years old
and uh me i'm insecure uh about uh being
alone right i'm insecure about that okay
uh we got dates coming up washington d.c
i will be there saturday washington dc
you go to crystalia.com to get your
tickets then i will be in stockton then
i will be in oakland and i gotta get
bulletproof vests for those
[ __ ] although oakland seems to
be doing really nice nowadays right
uh but uh not stockton so anyway then
i'll be in peoria and rockford illinois
and then i got other ones coming up so
to go to crystalia.com and do that
you know what actually needs to be
actually might be helping with because i
had the word recall uh
[ __ ] with the gabapentin and now i got
the cbd that i'm taking
uh pure spectrum
if you use uh go to the website uh and
use code congrats you get 10 off of that
they got gummies bro they got all this
[ __ ] they got
bath
[ __ ] bath you could put in your bath
and just [ __ ]
toke out in the bath there's no thc but
you can toke out in the bath and just
[ __ ] you know
helps good with the restless leg
syndrome my anxiety's been lower and
honestly dude i just been [ __ ] at a
more leveled kind i was at a wedding
recently and i go i feel pretty good is
it the cbd and my wife goes oh no but
i'm arguing so
ten percent off go to the website uh
code congrats
uh and uh yeah
but yeah so i'm [ __ ] going on tour i
can't wait to get out there atlanta's
already sold out b.o.b is coming [ __ ]
told me he's coming shout out to bob
love b.o.b b.o.b is a fan of the [ __ ]
podcast so sue me all right amit his
chick
um
put me in a song too i believe you put
me in the beginning of a song i can't
remember what the [ __ ] song was but
me laughing or something or saying
congratulations i don't know dude
whatever dude it is what it is
and we keep we keep pushing right um
i came home the other day
look i'm not going to be one of those
boring people that talks about the
weather but we got it something's got to
give dude all right
something's got to give
it's 108 degrees in los angeles where
the [ __ ] are we baghdad is it even hot
there i have no idea i'm an idiot where
the [ __ ] are we uh in uh pakistan it's
definitely hot there right i don't know
i don't [ __ ] know dude is it where
are we hell how about that dude it's 108
degrees and it's drier than a
[ __ ] i walk outside i had
man it's the kind of thing where
we're not ready for this that's the
thing i want it to be as hot as it's
gonna get i don't want it to be hotter
than that the second you have that heat
wave week
it's like la can't deal and la can't
deal with the rain there's la deals with
the weather
on this [ __ ] sort of a pendulum right
if it gets further out rainy or further
out hot we're [ __ ]
if it snows god forbid everyone stays
indoor
indoors
because i'm going to play chicago a
little bit of a slip but oopsy daisy but
also i'm letting you know i'm going to
let you i'm going to wet your beak a
little bit
right i'm going to wet the appetite i'll
be in chicago when it's really [ __ ]
cold in february i believe is what i'm
doing the date and i'm like can we even
sell tickets and they laughed they were
like yeah we can sell tickets they come
out even if it's snowing it's not la and
i felt a little bit love you know i was
like okay
uh so it's hot as [ __ ] it's 108 degrees
and i'm not joking it's 108 degrees and
people in arizona right now are like so
who gives a [ __ ] and people in baghdad
right now are like so well does it
matter but i'm telling you right now
it's too hot
for los angeles and how do i know
how do i know it's too hot for los
angeles because dude breaking news
i killed a [ __ ] scorpion in my
doorway the other day
a scorpion
a scorpion
a scorpion but it's okay it was a small
one but then i googled it those are the
more poisonous ones why because they
need to rely on poison not their pincers
a scorpion
filled with poison
at my door
like it's a jehovah's witness
at my door like it's a hare krishna at
my door like it's a mormon missionary
at my door
like it's selling me girl scout cookies
but it doesn't have all that it doesn't
have a white button down with short
sleeves and a tie it doesn't have that
orange [ __ ] robe that they wear it
doesn't have any of that it just has a
[ __ ] tail ready to attack dude
a scorpion now i've been in los angeles
for 23
years that's a long time okay 23 [ __ ]
years
some people die before that
some people die before they're 23. i've
lived in los angeles a lifetime that's
what i'm telling you dude i've seen a
scorpion
one time and it was when i was just
watching by mistake scorpion king it's
the worst movie of all time but i've
never seen a scorpion except for on
youtube or when i'm in arizona i've seen
scorpions okay but there was a scorpion
in los angeles california
and i saw it and it was just chilling at
my doorway i got home it was late at
night
they come out at night
because that's when
you know it gets hot dude it wanted it
indoors man and this even the scorpion
was like really nighttime come on get
the [ __ ] out of here we're going in
dude it was ridiculous
and i was scared i was scared of [ __ ]
dude
but guess what i did
i overcame it
now whereas if it wasn't a spider or a
scorpion would i have killed it no if it
was an ant even if it was a big ant
i would have probably shoot it away i
would have probably kicked it right even
if it was a b i probably would have
flicked it like there was a b on
calvin's floaty the other day and
kristen says there's a b on it you might
want to do something about it now i
wasn't worried because calvin's been
stung before and we know he's not
allergic so we're past that [ __ ] he's
two and a half i took the b i lined it
up ping flicked it out it hit the side
it was on the ground for a little bit
thought maybe i killed it and then it
just kind of walked away right
i think i probably
ended up flying i didn't kill it okay
that's my point i'm very good with
nature and i'm nice with nature okay
i don't [ __ ] break off branches and i
try not to kill bees unless they're
around write somebody that like if i
didn't know kevin was allergic
or not and b was around i would kill the
bee right
but a scorpion dude
so i looked at it and i [ __ ] stomped
it and i dragged it all in the house
when you dre when you man it was like it
was like i shot somebody
there was so much mess
it was like
and and it was a mess and then there was
like its body was still there like
scraped
it was like a [ __ ] i needed to take
cut like little [ __ ] spokes and
little caution tape for crime scene and
put the outline of the scorpion with the
[ __ ] white little white tape with the
little tail scooped up you know but dude
it was uh it was a menace man it was at
my door knocking and then i [ __ ]
killed it
and i walk up and one of my friends was
over with kristen and i say hey
i just killed a scorpion and she says
really and i say yeah
and then i go to kristen and i say i
just killed the scorpion and she said
really and i will and i said yeah she
said where was i told her where it was
we saw the body do it it was just like
this this is what the scorpion was like
this
so anyway i googled it and i was like
okay
it wasn't a purple you ever see a big
purple if i saw a big purple one forget
it dude forget it
first the spider's in seattle and now
this the scorpions big scorpions they
have armor and [ __ ] they look like they
belong in game of thrones
and uh
and so i uh
i killed it and then i googled it and it
said you'll never see
multiple scorpions together like they're
lone wolves and i'm just like [ __ ] yeah
dude maybe i'm like a scorpion dude
because that's kind of how i am right
i'm the scorpion
you know i don't really like to [ __ ]
with people because i don't trust them
scorpions you know what scorpions are
like tupac they're the tupac of the
arachnids they're like yeah but trust no
one that's what a scorpion's like and
that's what i'm like you see a little
scorpion with the two little pinchers
and a [ __ ] backwards bandana tied
like aunt jemima but it's tupac with a
[ __ ] chain and a cross and a thing
that says 50 scorpions on his chest
with a z
that's me dude i'm the lone scorpion
i don't [ __ ] with nobody dude but i
killed him it was either me or my
[ __ ] son getting
sniped and hurt you know
[ __ ] scared to see a scorpion for the
first time ever people think i'm lying
dude i'm like dude
so anyway i killed a scorpion i'm
[ __ ] awesome if there was one of
those blue ones i would have got a
[ __ ] shield god i don't like doing
that
i don't like uh doing any of that
killing [ __ ] it makes me feel bad a
little bit i used to i used to think it
was clever when i was a kid people would
be like i'd be like ask me if i'm a
killer and they'd be like are you a
killer and it'd be like yeah and they
like you never killed anyone i'd be like
kill dance and then i would [ __ ] walk
away like like that's so something a
nine-year-old would do that would think
would that thing that that would think
he's badass
there's too much [ __ ] on instagram i
gotta get instagram's the only one i go
on
i do post on tick tock and then i
[ __ ] i don't ever really look at
comments and [ __ ]
instagram's the only one where sometimes
i'll catch a comment dude right it's the
only one
and i watch it and then i see like the
kanye west [ __ ] it just makes me sad
right like hey he's having a manic
episode hey somebody help that guy hey
guy yeah it's good when people are like
but it's good for publicity it helps his
pockets yeah okay oh but he's probably
releasing an album or a documentary yeah
okay but what about his mental what
about how he's doxing everybody at
adidas right now just posting pictures
of old white dudes and jackie joyner
kersey hey it's [ __ ] their lives up
dude
just posting all sorts of [ __ ]
he says sometimes i dress like it's
winter when my house outfit is hot
sometimes i dress like it's winter when
it's hot because my outfit hot i'ma
sweat before you catch me looking
regular at the bet awards this n word
that work at universal asked me i was
asked me was i hot i told this n-word
you work at universal lol
silliness also dude
not even a bad job
well universal is a [ __ ] working at
universal is good they got [ __ ] good
dental right
like you got [ __ ] health insurance
this is a [ __ ] job everybody would
want and this guy's like
also how about how aren't you hot isn't
even a snake this
aren't you hot it's just oh man are you
sure you wanna are you hot are you
sweating
didn't [ __ ] uh
uh martin lawrence collapsed cause he
was wearing too many layers this guy
could have just been [ __ ] concerned
and this guy goes and then kanye says
you work at universal ha ha
siddiq
so dick wasn't even remotely shitty
are you hot you work at universal [ __ ]
face oh oh okay
and then people are putting out there
about how like kanye there he goes again
and it helps his ticket sales and it
helps albums or whatever the [ __ ] this
guy's losing his mind dude and then he
said he was gonna go to the weekend
concert and that's what i call him the
weakened
because there's no e it's the weakened
if that's what he wants to spell it
that's how we're all saying it dude the
weakened
so he went to the wiccan concert and
dude and he was saying how there was
going to be no security find me if you
want to find me dude this guy's going to
get [ __ ] this guy's going to get his
wig pushed back dude
[ __ ] man i want to get a bulletproof
vest i really do and i want to do my
shows like the [ __ ] tupac comedian
that's what i want to do and kristen
said don't get a bulletproof vest and i
said dude i get death threats
and she's like i know but it seems like
you're egging them on and i go all right
well you know if i do get shot in the
chest then what
you're going to wish i got a [ __ ] you
know i wish i got something you're going
to wish i got something with no sleeves
in me and black dude you're going to
wish i got something vinyl with no
sleeves on man
i rocked the [ __ ] out of that put over a
[ __ ] t-shirt look ill [ __ ]
i don't know man i'm just sad for kanye
honestly man i know it seems like he has
it all but dude that guy's got [ __ ]
he's out what's up with the yes man dude
help him out
take some [ __ ] cbd dude
take some cbd smoke some weed i don't
know man
i just feel bad dude i really do feel
bad
i want kanye to be okay i want everybody
at adidas to be okay
you know dachshund people online isn't
cool
i think that uh we need to [ __ ] help
each other out and love each other a
little bit more right
i think we do
adidas offered him one billion dollars
and he said no i want two billion
imagine being that
and they said he need and he said he
wants to keep the yeezy brand and he
said all the sorts of [ __ ] that are
under his terms
and you this is just not going to let
that go you know yeezy is 60 or
60-something percent of adidas sales
that's crazy dude that is so crazy this
guy is adidas this guy is a force to be
reckoned with but he's not all mentally
there feel bad for him want him to get
help
willie
i don't know man when you're that big
what's it matter what's that thing
called escape velocity you can't touch
these [ __ ] right you can't
touch these [ __ ]
you know it doesn't matter what this
dude does you can't touch him
uh is that what that's called escape
velocity i think it is let me look it up
escape velocity i mean every you know
it's like
how do i make it
how do i make another there we go escape
the la
city
the speed in which is some of an
object's kinetic energy
a rocket continuously accelerated by its
exhaust can escape without ever reaching
escape speed since wow am i a scientist
dude
what is escape velocity the minimum
velocity that a moving body such as a
rocket must have to escape from
gravitational field of a celestial body
such as earth and move outward into
space and that's exactly what i'm kind
of talking about maybe i think i heard
it somewhere i can't remember but
whatever dude
i i heard it somewhere i can't remember
where um
was it on rogan's podcast what the [ __ ]
was it i don't know um
anyway dude you work out universal
plebeian
uh
speaking of mentally not ill
and speaking of
speaking of mentally ill and mentally
like not all
there
um
i am
i am a uh
i am this is not the thing i wanted huh
i wanted the [ __ ] i'm i'm in a feud
i'm in a hip-hop feud i'm a hip-hop dude
and i'm in a hip-hop feud
that's why i say don't push me bro
but he wants to push me busy bone wants
to push me dude
he wants to push me this is not the
[ __ ] link
one fire put the link on the thing and
this is not the link
he wants to push me though baby
busy bone
wants
he wants smoke and it's fine and look
here's the thing dude i was a big fan of
bone dogs and harmony way back when and
i think i talked let me just let's break
down this where's this video dude let's
get this video i may have to cut because
i need to get this video and [ __ ] of
course one fire send me a video of a car
video this works
on the thing
okay let me get it
why did it start with a car
did i click the wrong thing
let me do it right now you're going to
want to hear this
pardon me dude as he said to me part of
my [ __ ] interruption you're
going to want to hear this dude
oh i don't know why it had a different
thing here we go all right dude here it
is
bone thugs in harmony member busy bone
so here's the deal i told a story on the
[ __ ] podcast a while ago and it was
about how i was at the comedy store with
my brother and faison love all right you
might know him from friday we were
hanging out talking and in the middle of
the conversation busy bone walks up to
us and wants to say something to faison
love now he says pardon my [ __ ]
pardon the interruption pardon the
interruption didn't need all that we
were like what the [ __ ] is going on
yelling and screaming poured in the
interruption pardon the [ __ ]
interruption pardon my [ __ ]
interrupts he kept saying it must have
said it 12 times told the story in the
podcast said he didn't need to interrupt
that art didn't know what it was i hope
that he's all good wanted to talk to
faison love
talked to face on love a little bit
walked away and that was my whole
experience with busy bone all right now
it was on some hypno hip-hop news
outlets for a little bit and it said
crystalia talks about busy bone of
course the media ran with it like
crystalline is talking [ __ ] about busy
bone but that's what happened don't know
what busy bones saw
don't know how he took it because again
not oh mentally there who is though not
me
who is though no hate on busy bone think
he's very talented in 1999 and that's
fine
all right the one issue i had with both
dogs and harmony is everyone was they
had 95 songs about how everyone was
trying to rip bone thugs and harmony off
and these bone clones were out there
trying to [ __ ] jack their style when
it's like huh
there was nobody like them and there
never was and that's why they were
[ __ ] awesome for three years and then
weren't now no hate
there's still bone [ __ ] out
there that want to be out there and be
like you know i mean dude honestly when
they said asan giving up for chatter for
cheesy food got it i felt that [ __ ] dude
right
when they said it i'm giving it up for
easy for god's got it i'm gonna miss
everybody and now that's when i was sat
back and i was like you know what these
lyrics actually mean something to me
so
say what you want they got a fan base
and i'm all for it dude
but like i say in the hat don't push me
i said what i said cause it happened
with no hate but he wanted to pardon the
interruption and he did and we let him
talk to face on love don't know what he
said because after that i was astonished
and my brother and i were looking at
each other like wow and i said is that
busy bone and my brother said yeah and i
said that's crazy
so now busy bone goes on this [ __ ]
thing streams live and starts talking
[ __ ] about yours truly me
and now as a 19 year old when i was
listening to [ __ ] bone thugs and
harmony listening
i'm going to miss everybody on now
apesam
listening to listening to it in tim
chung's forerunner as we're going to get
[ __ ] jack-in-the-box at lunch period
right
i never thought that i would be this 42
year old man still young as [ __ ] spring
chicken a little bit of salt and pepper
but it's nice right
and i've got beef with busy bone
and this is what he says in his video
man i wrote some stuff about tupac and
tupac said i don't know what about him
i said well that [ __ ] still holds true
today then the [ __ ] just started
butting on tupac okay here we go yeah
but he's a contradiction after this i dm
the dude special i said
the house the house
what the hell did tupac do to you okay
here we go
what did pop do to you were you even
alive when pop was alive here we go what
the [ __ ] did he do come on
okay so that you know that's that's just
let's get down
to the real [ __ ] okay cool
by the way thank you for calling my [ __ ]
the real [ __ ] i don't know what it was
before that i didn't watch the whole
thing but he was [ __ ] he was doing
some [ __ ] stuff i guess but this is
the real [ __ ] okay great
all right i gotta stand up for this [ __ ]
oh he's bad he's mad at me
this is real
in front of the move the chair three
comedians y'all and i want y'all to pay
close [ __ ] attention it's been
three comedians that has in
specifically in specifically
no i i honestly and specifically did do
that so
or busy bomb okay and jim
okay
first of all we're gonna deal with chris
the [ __ ]
[Music]
of middle school
chris
de [ __ ]
dude
oh that's a song give it up for china
for these things for god's got it come
on man
i ain't gonna say your whole name your
whole ass [ __ ] they know it's
me and i'm not a whole ass [ __ ]
they know it's me and they know me dude
and you know something about me i'm not
a hoe ass [ __ ] dude so here we
go dude we're on we're on dude i'm i
this is
oh all right let's listen and i haven't
listened to this whole thing yet because
i wanted to do with you guys
so chris the [ __ ]
running with it dude i'm not a ho-ass
[ __ ] busy bone dude you want to
smoke
i'll perform in cleveland no bulletproof
vest
says he supposedly met me yep
at sun show my show i was supposedly
this
angel no you were not an [ __ ] you
just had pardon my interruption 19 times
didn't understand what was going on and
it was not at some show it was at the
comedy store here we go okay first and
foremost
when i'm in my zone cool
man i can't have nobody around me great
so you were in the zone when i'm about
to get on stage wait a minute dude what
okay
but you're not a comedian so what do you
mean when you're about to get on stage
were you playing a house of blues no you
weren't because it was already
demolished by that time across the
street from the comedy store so let's go
electric okay and these people have paid
for a show right like the people at the
company
hold on i'm drinking i'm smoking you
know i'm none of that like i'm focused
like all right let's get these people
the best show in the world baby come on
oh he must be talking about it
you know your lines your boys know
exactly where you're breathing at the
show is perfect you just make sure you
do the right stuff cool don't do too
much don't do too little
i mean that's what's going on in my mind
okay that's good you trying to come up
to me
and and like before the show yeah and be
like
hey man how are you man i mean i am in a
zone we finna get crazy up here
he
did he listen to the video dude
on the thing on the on this podcast i
said it was at the comedy store it was
my show he either saw it or he didn't if
he didn't then don't talk about it but
if you want to smoke dude
i'm going to give you four free tickets
to any show you want to come to come
come actually you know what i'm going to
give you 20 free tickets come with all
of the bone thugs and all the bone
clones dude
we could talk this out
so you ain't gonna really get no
conversation that don't make me an a-ha
you came up to me
it just don't i'm not a young blood is
better from trying to cap and think i'm
not gonna answer you right away bro i'm
not gonna give you what you asking for
i'm not gonna get to you later no i'm
just gonna get to you later i mean i
mean made it up all in his head you
gotta understand what somebody in their
zone is i was in the zone it was my show
i was talking to face on love he was on
the show too
and i had fail
it was my show if anyone's in the zone
i'm in the zone dude don't twist it like
you're in the zone
you weren't in the zone then i was in
the zone and you were interrupting me in
the zone
somebody and they craft and they
mastering they crap man they're not
trying to joke
i'm ready to explode on this
[ __ ] stage my man wow so that's
the first thing so he got all on his
little website he got off my god on his
website 60 years old dude got on his
webs are you talking [ __ ] about me on
your website
got all on this website you know what i
mean uploaded some videos to funny or
die checked out ebon's world you know
this [ __ ] got on there man
he went on aol got in some chat rooms
started talking [ __ ] about busy bone
you know it's low you know it's no
podcast there you go you know i got it
bro
you know i got a podcast
that does stupid numbers you know dude
stop hiding behind this [ __ ] on my
website double website too you can get
merch there but come on dude i wasn't
talking [ __ ] on my website you know what
it is it's on the critically acclaimed
congratulations podcast dude whatever
hell are you talking about yeah you
don't have busy bones
bad impression of me like you know me
[ __ ] if i didn't even [ __ ] don't call
me that why don't nobody say nothing
about flesh that's my only question
why don't nobody they always come to the
light skin [ __ ] man god damn i gotta
always fight for my love
like he's having fun with the honesty
okay cool i like that i ain't gonna keep
going on and on about that but you know
it would be nice if you really felt some
kind of a way dm i don't feel seeing you
at the show really didn't get an eye it
was my show i liked what you do no i
wasn't saying use me for clout and think
i'm fine i'm not using busy bone for
clouds
it's not what happened
so now i'm in a [ __ ] beef with a hip
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude
dude now i have a [ __ ] hip-hop beef
[ __ ] dude
get these at chrisley.com
[ __ ] dude god damn it it's a new brown
one you get chris lee that gum [ __ ] dude
[ __ ] [ __ ]
periwinkle one you can get chris leather
come [ __ ] god damn it dude
i can't believe i have a [ __ ] hip-hop
beef now
sorry guys
[ __ ] jacket for the fall get chris
later come on [ __ ] god damn it
[ __ ] dude this is the new one i [ __ ]
my favorite one dude this [ __ ] the
life rips puffy one comes out it's a bad
[ __ ] christmas god damn it dude
i can't believe i have a hip hop beef
just because i told a story about how
[ __ ] busy boned goddamn
[ __ ] because busy bone [ __ ] what
do you call it he [ __ ] interrupted me
and faison love dude
just trying to hang out with my brother
matt can back it up faison probably
can't because he was high as [ __ ]
am i in a beef with faison now too dude
also dude man
you know
like i appreciate what you did for hip
hop man
i like busy bun and i like that he's
having fun and i like that he's kind of
doing it what is this a podcast or
whatever the [ __ ] i don't know what it
is but i like that he uses the he's got
an elliptical back there so that's cool
man he's trying he's good for you know i
mean i know he wants to be hardcore but
also he's into his health so he cares
about living you know how like rappers
like i don't give a [ __ ] i ain't afraid
to die you obviously are afraid to die
if you have a [ __ ] elliptical okay
because you're trying to stay healthy
that's all
so pardon my [ __ ] interruption
but
it's hard out here on these [ __ ]
streets to be honest
rappers and everybody is meant they're
all mentally ill you know everybody not
just rappers i shouldn't just say
rappers
huh
oh this [ __ ] happened the other day this
was
this was hilarious
um
racism does exist i know that like
top gun no not what i wanted 100 million
what i wanted not what i wanted skip the
ad is this an ad
um
all right so i was watching a a thing
the other day uh about how this black
family was trying to sell their home and
they were trying to sell it and they got
it appraised and it was appraised for
400 000
and they were like this doesn't feel
right because we did a lot of work on
the house and then they went to go uh
get it appraised but with a white family
so they took all their pictures out of
their black family all of that had some
black artwork or whatever the [ __ ] and
and um
they moved they they
no remnants of of anything black in
there no no no no pictures no nothing
and then they had a white family get the
[ __ ] of praise and they got appraised
for 300 000 more dude and that's crazy
now whatever you want to blame the
system the people the person who was
[ __ ] doing the appraisal whatever you
want to blame it has to do with racism
in some way all right okay like even if
you're like well they don't want to live
there that's not their fault if if they
don't want it's racist to not want to
live near blacks it's racist to not want
to live near [ __ ] whatever near
whites it's whatever it is there's
racism somehow whether it's in the
system or with each person or whatever
and i understand we're not going to
solve that tomorrow or whatever the [ __ ]
but um
that's crazy to me
like racism okay at some point i get it
like if you're gonna be 75 years old and
you're white and you just want to chill
with a bunch of other white people till
you die that's the amount of racist that
i think it's okay
right you're not outwardly doing
anything shitty towards any other race
if you're [ __ ] 85 years old and
you're black and you kind of just want
to chill with some black people till the
day you die and you don't really want to
be bothered by white people i get it
that's the level of racism that i think
is okay and we can also still function
nicely as a society
and i don't think that we can really get
beyond that i think that as humans we're
tribal and there's we have that in us
right okay okay
but
300 000
racist is insane dude
but this stuff happens look it happened
this stuff happens is it okay it's not
okay it's hard it sucks and it leads to
all sorts of other [ __ ] that [ __ ] up
the world and it's bad now i know
because i'm a smart person that that's
bad okay
but this
this was great
there was a guy a black guy watering i
mean not great but there was a black guy
watering his neighbor's plants because
of
the the the neighbors left town and they
wanted this dude to look after the
plants and he came over and was watering
the plants for the people
and someone a warm late spring evening
in the small alabama town of
childersburg police are responding to a
911 i mean this guy's a voice dude have
you ever heard i was by the way this
voice that people
a black pastor arrested while watering
neighbors flowers he was supposed to be
doing it but someone called of
suspicious behavior and dude like that's
always the voice you know it's either
that or like this is how it is in sports
events dude have you ever seen a
sporting event where the guys don't talk
like that i have college college
football
i watch college football i watch the
seminals versus the [ __ ] uh
i don't know who cares who cares really
but i watched them and this and they
were just dudes that were like oh man
whoa whoa oh wow threw it over there
whoa that's crazy oh look at that oh
yeah it's a touchdown hey all right he
got a touchdown it was not of this stuff
and it was so [ __ ] weird dude you got
to have the voice this is the voice
we're all accustomed to have the voice
my neighbor reporting she sees a young
black male in the car
she doesn't recognize at her neighbor's
home who she knows are away
we're watching the police body cam
footage what officers find is a man
holding a garden hose
watering flowers
intimidating
it's so great all right been black his
whole life
just
absolutely knows what's about to go down
you know what i'm talking about dude
imagine black people doing this [ __ ] and
doing nothing at all and then the cops
show up and they're just like here the
[ __ ] we goddamn go again dude this guy
couldn't be doing something more
peaceful even if he is
at a stranger's house he's still helping
he's watering the plants it's hot out
even if it is a suspicious person dude
if i if i walk out if i'm if i peek
outside someone's watering my plants i
don't give a [ __ ] who they are i don't
say nothing i let them finish up and
leave then i don't have to do it
are they saying that is that your
vehicle
it's not it's the neighbors
the neighbors
okay
you live here no i don't even
okay uh they saying that this vehicle is
not supposed to be here and you're not
supposed to be here
they called about it i don't know who
caught
i'm supposed to be here i'm pastor
jennings i live across the street dude
he's a pastor of all couldn't be more
innocent dude
couldn't
be
more innocent
just
nah nah nah uh uh that's cute man i'm
supposed to be here just start spraying
like just knows what's up oh you're
gonna be racist okay i'm pastor
[ __ ] the
subdued
gotcha in his voice oh no i'm supposed
to be here i'm pastor without looking
and spraying is so the [ __ ] dude what's
saying i'm not supposed to be here no
i'm supposed to be here i'm a pastor
you're pastor jenny yes i'm looking out
for their house while they go the scene
quickly escalates when police demand 56
year old michael jennings a pastor of 31
years provide some identification
look man don't do this to me
there's a suspicious person in the yard
and if you're not wanting to identify
yourself i don't have to identify myself
still spraying
if i ain't did nothing suspicious i
nothing wrong moments later when
jennings attempts to use his cell phone
he's placed in handcuffs
who called y'all
i don't have the idea you will not
listen i have a call on you all right
i don't know what you know i get
i get like comply i get it i get that
like cops can do whatever they really
can do whatever they want it's like you
have no right it's used for you to say
to a cop you have no right to do this
they get you on something you know like
they i get it but for having to deal
with this [ __ ] their whole lives i under
i also understand that look [ __ ]
i'm not doing anything people are out
there robbing and stealing and [ __ ] let
me just water these goddamn plants
because i'm black you [ __ ]
i was called obviously what like why
what where's what i don't get about and
i support the i'm not one of these
[ __ ] that's like [ __ ] defund
the police i think that's utterly
[ __ ] idiotic we need police the crime
in la sucks because they don't have
enough the police don't have enough
money because [ __ ] we're we're cucks
you know what i'm saying is too liberal
all right so by no means am i saying oh
defund the police [ __ ] the police [ __ ]
all cop nah i the we need them okay i
want all the cops i want more cops all
right
but
i don't understand why when a cop shows
up
to this house
and sees what's actually happened they
don't say oh i get what's happening
it's racism
ah
racism again
the only thing that i can understand is
is that the cops are racist and maybe
they are maybe they are but they're not
racist cause they're cops
people have all sorts of
different levels of racism you know and
i think that it's kind of like i said
we're tribal and if you want to be 80 an
asian and only hang out with asian
people that's the amount on racism
that's totally down but 300 000 racism
this is how much it is this is beyond
this is 300 000 racist that's what that
is
i don't know why cops don't show up and
they say oh he's watering oh yeah the
[ __ ] chick she was probably white
let's go [ __ ] talk to her
because then they're like well why don't
you show us the identification we have
to arrest you if you don't and then the
black guy is like well i shouldn't have
to do that just because i'm black and
you get the thing and i get it
let it go dude
let it go
let it go
that's what the [ __ ] disney song's
about racism secretly
homie no we let it go
let it go
let it go
i i don't know what anything is anymore
honestly i see j cole on the [ __ ] nba
2k cover and i'm just like what
how how long do we have to pretend that
j cole is [ __ ] good about this is the
thing remember the [ __ ] uh
master p how he was kind of good at
basketball
and [ __ ] and there was that rumor that
hanging with mr cooper almost made it on
the [ __ ] hornets or whatever the hell
it was i don't care about those
and people are like yeah j cole's
actually good
all right you know not re okay
okay
and now he's on the cover of [ __ ]
nba 2k
that'd be like a [ __ ] guy fieri was
on the cover of this [ __ ]
you just don't do the thing
oh yeah oh yeah but oh yeah but i cook
there's a [ __ ] cooking video game
yeah but i cook at home oh we'll put you
on the cover no you put guy fiery on the
[ __ ] if guy fieri on this [ __ ] with a
[ __ ] goddamn raptors jersey on
so weird dude
i don't like the sports video games dude
my [ __ ] buddy loves the sports video
games loves playing them
and it's just like and i'm like you get
it every year he's like i get madden
every single year and i say what's
different and they said just like the
updates and the stat and the the players
and [ __ ] and i'm just like but the
game's the same and he's like usually oh
you sucker dude
nba2k23
and i want the games also how about this
dude video games i want you to stop
being
stop with the realism
just fun fun all right
fun
i don't want the oh but you see the
sweat coming off i don't oh you remember
tecmo ball
you remember nba jam
what the [ __ ] video game basketball
video game is better than nba jam and
you gotta you yeah but the and you could
trade and i don't want to buy [ __ ]
how much money do you have as a team
manager [ __ ] off
are you want to do manage mode nah i
want a ball that's why i'm out dude
it's too real it makes it less fun
i'm not into it
um
i want to jump on somebody's head and
[ __ ] warp through a a [ __ ] green
pipe that's what i want
i gotta take a break it's so hot
yeah it was too you know that's the
thing about the heat i had to cut
because it just gets i mean i went to
the bathroom and my my underwear is just
soaked a little too much information but
whatever dude and you know what what i
was thinking in there is there's like 16
or 17 patreon episodes that we have so
if you sign up for the patreon
patreon.com then you can uh go watch
them all now uh what are you doing
um
yeah
the other oh dude you want to know what
happened [ __ ] this is hilarious um
so
i was on
i was uh
i took calvin to see
his his my mom
which is obviously his grandma she calls
herself gammy
and he says gami
going to gammy's and so uh i took him
kristen had to stay here and do uh some
work and um i took them and then she was
watching that that [ __ ] a seminal
game whatever the [ __ ]
uh and who was it oh and lsu i think
that later no i don't remember what it
doesn't matter dude why am i trying to
think of it
so and um
and she was like
oh my god this game we're on a group
text because mike linochie loves our
buddy who's a funny comedian loves
flora he went there to wherever the
florida summit sfu and she was like this
game is crazy she wrote crazy
c-r-a-t-z-y
and i sent a voice note and i said oh
wow like on the text i said this game
really is crazy as a j i said this game
is [ __ ] crazy right that's what i did
and i didn't think that calvin he was in
the back seat
i knew he was in the back seat because i
was coming home from gammy's and then he
goes and then he goes that's [ __ ]
crazy and i was like oh oh no so i
started recording it
why can't it why would it play up and
here we go here we go hurry
what'd you say i said
that's crazy
you heard it okay cool okay a little bit
of what i said a relief yes what did i
say
i wanted to make sure
[ __ ] crazy yeah it's crazy
there you go yeah
that's so funny man
so cute dude
what'd you say i said
that's crazy he's a good boy
okay cool
is that what i said
yeah what did i say
it's
[ __ ] crazy yeah it's crazy
oh that's so cute dude he goes he goes
like this it's [ __ ] crazy like oh
like he just learned a new word dude i
love being his dad man
that's so cute man everybody's been a
child how about that man how about that
everybody's been a child even busy bone
right and he grew up to be a guy that
interrupts me and face on love and my
brother family family time pardon the
[ __ ] interruption um so yeah
that's so cute dude wow so funny he's
been funny man i want to know when it
stops getting funnier as a dad i know a
lot of you are dads out there dude it
just keeps being funny it keeps being
funny he starts he keeps saying [ __ ] and
it keeps making us laugh i don't even do
i have so much material on my son now
that like come out crystal.com i got on
tour but like i got so many [ __ ]
jokes about my son i have to [ __ ]
stop doing them because it's i can't
have it all be about my son uh but it's
so fun to talk about him too
uh i'm going to atlanta i'll be in
atlanta on friday and um
my dad is coming out he's working in
atlanta and it's so cool because calvin
knows that when he goes to daddy's work
pop-pop's gonna be there it's pop-up and
gammy that's what they're called
that's what life's about man
that's what life's about
um
yeah man so uh
what else did that was funny he did
something else that was [ __ ]
hilarious the other day
i don't remember because of the [ __ ]
i need ginkgo biloba
i need more pure spectrum gummies uh
let's do some of these uh deserve it
scales here
and then we'll do some dessert skills
and then we'll do some tinder i don't
know i kind of like the tinder stuff
more but we'll do some of these
[Music]
we don't need the music
oh [ __ ] dude oh
oh [ __ ] this guy [ __ ] this tree tried
to [ __ ]
[ __ ] him
dude the way the tree falls well that
guy's lucky as [ __ ] could have been
killed
oh if he stood on it that would have
been a
that would have been if he stood on it
and balanced well of course he didn't
because he's [ __ ] fat and bald but
dude if he stood on it in balance that
guy immediately is in my family i don't
give a [ __ ] what anyone says he's a
family member of mine because i get to i
i get to adopt him in my family because
that would be amazing
that he don't know if you deserve that i
don't chop down trees you know
maybe maybe maybe you deserved it but
don't jump don't treat that was funny
bro
here we go here's another one attempting
to do some sort of stunt involving a
beer can some sort of stunt nose makes
you know it went way wrong
i mean why is his face painted like a
lion
all unnecessary dude
just
was he trying to catch it afterwards
oh
wow that was uh well that's a an eight
or a 9.
throws it up
and then
in a parking garage too
so unforgiving dude
oh my god that's an eight for sure that
guy got fi that lion got hurt
why is he [ __ ] painted like he's at
state fair so drunk with his paris with
a ball main paris hoodie on and then
just here's another one what could go
wrong using an escalator as a conveyor
belt okay
what
a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
dude no
they took away the gurney yeah wow this
is so something that would happen in an
asian country i'm sorry i know that's
racist but it just is dude actually i
could see a white person doing it she
put it on the conveyor belt the [ __ ]
thing the the for those you listening
the suitcase she put a suitcase on a
conveyor belt and it and it or on an
escalator it it
tipped over and [ __ ] shot down and
hit this woman on the bottom that was
just like some lady you ever see some
lady get hurt that sucks
oh no
move a little bit she's running dude
like she's running from jason voorhees
wow that's amazing she didn't deserve it
though but the other
oh man can you sue somebody for that or
what's the deal that's horrible what is
that
she would be like i didn't mean to yeah
she didn't mean to oh it sucks man give
her 50 or some [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] using a table as a diving board
that's why they have diving boards
jumping on the table see this is the
thing they they jumped on the end of the
table like it was a diving board
because they had that in their head it
was muscle memory that's great this is a
[ __ ] eight
oh that looks like it hurts and the
whole table falls on him and the other
[ __ ] chick is laughing in there so
shitty dude also why is she wearing full
clothes this whole thing makes no sense
it's also in the rain this whole thing's
bad
happened in virginia no doubt but dude
it's so
oh her shins are done
all right let's look at these tinders
um
no thanks here we go mackenzie 25.
must want lots of children looking for a
life partner here that means no hookups
i'm very caring
i would love to have a big family and to
continue to be a stay-at-home mom until
my last child is in school and then
would like to go to school to get a
career most likely in the health field i
do suffer badly from my mental health
so i am not great at keeping a clean
house my biggest flaw also do not enjoy
cooking or sexually touching people oh
the last one was where it kind of
i feel like men can deal with a lot as
long as that's there
this is a joke also
she's
uh
i feel like i thought anyone named
mckenzie was kind of a [ __ ]
that's like one of those like nikki
names or something you know
mackenzie and you're just you're like
you're like you don't go to [ __ ]
florida state you know
that's a really bad uh and you don't
keep the house clean which is fine but
if you stay at home it's like here we go
a for effort are you single she says yes
of course aren't you she says no i have
a bf
oh to be honest i'm not interested in
using a dating app to talk with people
who are already in a relationship hope
you find what makes you happy good luck
she says can i still suck you until you
come
i feel like yeah
you know
okay um
you know until you come it's like the i
love how specific people get and dirty
talk sometimes it's hilarious here we go
did we did he ruin it hey
and then the girl says hello william
what's going on not much just woke up
from a nap
nice lol what you doing tonight haven't
thought about it what are you up to
she says he says i'm at my buddy's house
he's away
he says house sitting
i'm feeding his cat and just chilling
here at lowell yeah kinda
um
okay
i'm s
uh
and says aren't you good friend and he
says i need some company
she says i'm giving it serious thought
he says
lol are you joking
she says i'm seriously thinking about it
i'm not joking
and then he says
well we could have some fun
she says i know wow this is like a
podcast i'm gripped
like what's gonna happen dude this is
like one of those [ __ ]
who the bleep did i marry podcasts
uh not gonna lie i've been horny all day
sorry to be up front
she says so it will be a short
performance then
says no
it won't i have been drinking
oh god a
drunk stranger red flag ha ha
he says i don't know if you do coke lol
but there's some here if you do that
she says keep digging
i know that's random just saying she
says what the [ __ ] william
says
lol i didn't know if you were into that
lol but i'm not doing just saying would
be good
she says
all my spidey senses are tingling i'm
going to have to pass oh god this guy
had it in the back he says did i ruin it
i'm not doing it let
[Laughter]
the hail mary here is great did i ruin
it i'm not doing it let me bend you over
oh the hail mary dude
well she didn't like the drugs talk let
me [ __ ] go back to what it was let me
bend you over dude
this woman would have to be
wow that was that was maybe my favorite
one let me bend you
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] i shouldn't like the coke talk
let me bend you over ah
unromantic dude
at least mention kissing you know jesus
christ
let me not look at you
wow did i ruin it let me mess you over
to let me back over
came after did i ruin it amazing dude
my favorite tinder interaction of all
time here we go this way do you want to
[ __ ]
no she says why
she says because i don't feel respected
okay fair uh okay fair enough sorry just
to let you know though i meant no
disrespect i found you attractive and
thought being straightforward on an app
like this could work
that's i've tried that that's how i got
in trouble she says straightforwardness
is a very
nice thing especially in our current
culture i'm sorry that i snapped at you
he says no worries i probably shouldn't
have started with something as crass as
that fair enough definitely
we live and we learn um she says well
damn look at us being mature adults he
says i and one of those emojis
and then she says awkwardly fist bumps
back do you want to retry this entire
conversation and the guy says for sure
can't promise i won't fist bump though
all right fine you want to go first or
me she says you can go first i'll follow
your lead okay bet and then he says
do you want to [ __ ]
let her down dude
oh man
i try to leave but they just keep
pulling me back in that's what he said
oh that's great dude honestly that
deserves at least an otp hj that
deserves at least an otp hj that is
unbelievable dude that he did that he
strung her along that whole time and
then just hit her with the same [ __ ] as
a joke that guy is a full [ __ ]
comedian that's great dude also her
name's alyssa and alyssa is pretty much
up there with mackenzie on the
you know you know what i'm talking about
you go to florida state all right one
more and then we're out
oh god i bet you laughed out loud it's
called okay heart emoji and then they
write a smiley for a
cute smiley face what are you up to
working you just hanging out think about
those giant giant sweater yams that you
have oh my [ __ ] god dude okay that's
the guy
i can almost bet that you actually
laughed out loud when you read sweater
yams
and then she says oh no that's weird and
we're done here
i oh dude i can almost get
that's like [ __ ] david brent i almost
guarantee you left out loud no we're
done here ah okay
sensitive
um
wow dude
that's great
sweater yams you know not [ __ ] good
or funny at all gross hey guys that's it
for the episode here on youtube if you
want to catch the rest of the episode
the uncut raw uncensored video
and podcast all you got to do is head on
over to
patreon.comcrystalia and it's six bucks
and every episode is raw and uncut if
you sign up for the patreon and also
there's one extra episode a month a
whole episode there's like 16 or 17
episodes backlogged right now you can go
binge them right you go binge them like
like it's peaky blinders or something
all for just six bucks you get access to
that just right now we also do review
mode which is another segment uh and
some behind the scenes stuff we also
have a discord that we chat on i'ma get
on right now and talk to the people uh
you guys are great thank you very much
[Music]
you